I have a horrible Adam's Apple my my  voice sounds like this I still love  myself and there is almost money in  making people happy like it does cost a  lot of money that's why I can't get  surgeries that would make me a lot  happier but the point why but the point  of medicine is not supposed to be to  make you happy in the moment that's not  that's not the objective of medicine the  objective of medicine is your overall  wellness it's about treating what is  actually wrong that's that's medicine  and so if you are struggling to accept  who who you were born as what your  actual biological identity is I have all  the compassion in the world for that I  mean I can't imagine having that  disconnect in my head it has to be a  source of immense despair but what I  hate is the is the medical professionals  who instead of helping you with that and  help instead of helping you to accept  who you really are and find joy and  fulfillment in it  they're trying to make a quick buck